c'est donc une première une hydrolienne
est en cours d'installation en plein
coeur d'une ville orléans dans le
courant du plus grand fleuve français la
loire une hydrolienne fluvial comment ça
marche
c'est sur le même principe que les
éoliennes donc c'est basé sur le flux
d'eau sur la vitesse et avec la portance
des pales ont créé un couple qui fait
tourner la turbine
ces turbines d'une puissance nominale de
40 kg watts 40 kilos at c à peu près une
trentaine de foyers une puissance très
modeste donc sans rapport avec les
hydroliennes marine ou mieux encore les
éoliennes
il s'agit donc avec cette première
d'expérimentation c'est de tester en
situation réelle donc à la fois un site
naturel avec toutes les caractéristiques
d'un fleuve presque sauvage on peut dire
un des derniers en france voire en
europe également dans un
l'environnement urbain avec tout ce que
cela comporte en termes d'acceptabilité
d'impact paysager une zone natura 2000
donc une étude faune et flore très très
soigné très rigoureuse et en particulier
sur les poissons avec l'onema et
différents services de l'état par la
loire un millier de saumons remonte
encore de l'atlantique au massif central
ainsi que des lamproies des aloses toute
une faune dont il faudra observer le
comportement face à ce nouveau petit
obstacle
par exemple dans le cadre de la loire
l'impact que cela pourrait avoir sur la
migration des saumons
on sait bien que les obstacles sont déjà
un frein à la migration alors peut-être
qu'une seule ils reviennent posera pas
trop de problème les si on en mettait
plusieurs les unes à côté des autres
là on pourrait avoir un impact mais il
n'est pas question d'installer des parcs
de plusieurs dizaines d'hydroliennes en
loire le marché visé par hydro ques une
société grenobloise d'une dizaine
d'ingénieurs et celui de très grands
fleuves sur d'autres continents
pour cette expérience qui devrait
ensuite mené à la création d'une filière
industrielle française destinée à
l'export
la ville d'orléans engager 50 mille
euros de subvention au titre de son aide
au développement durable